alors bon soir l'un des missions peut
dire que les électeurs de la
circonscription de saint jérôme sont
ballottés entre des grandes vedettes la
dernière fois rappelez vous c'était
jacques duchesneau la grande surprise de
ce début de campagne ce pot si longtemps
fait 18 mois
cette fois-ci vous le savez pierre karl
péladeau dimanche dernier coup de
tonnerre dans cette campagne électorale
les faits pkp donc dans la campagne du
parti québécois c'est jérôme 68 mais les
électeurs taux de chômage de 7% revenu
moyen plus bas que la moyenne québécoise
dont il ya vraiment des poches de
pauvreté également importante à sa
gironde
j'ai rencontré les trois principaux
candidats
évidemment pierre karl péladeau patrick
charbonneau de la cac qui lui doit
prendre le relais de monsieur duchesneau
et armand dubois ancien journaliste de
tva
armand dubois qui quand il a vu à
l'écran la candidature de son ancien
patron d'une certaine façon il a décidé
de faire le saut et vincent
lemay-thivierge frère de l'autre lemay
thivierge comédiens candidats qui
étaient candidats la dernière fois pour
québec solidaire
alors j'ai rencontré tout ce beau monde
là ce matin à saint gérand
la bourgogne a cappella dont vous avez
un attrait dans le restaurant vous aller
saluer les gens est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous aimez faire quelle nature
et y en a pour qui c'est extrêmement dur
vous est ce que je vous ai vu faire ça
avec oui énormément puis testé soucie de
mon père mon père était très près des
gens et puis c'est probablement aussi la
raison pour laquelle j'ai toujours été
attentif à leurs attentes des personnes
plusieurs personnes ont dit journal de
montréal sur des commentaires mais ce
que pierre péladeau avait c'était d'être
près des gens de croire leur procurer un
journal en l'occurrence qui allait
retenir leur attention leurs
préoccupations de quoi les gens vous
parlent s'est passé quand même quelques
jours ici là à saint-girons
j'avais quelques heures pour saint jean
et jean vous parle en priorité de ce
qu'elle dirait que la première réaction
c'est le bonheur de
quoique décidé de me présenter j'ai omis
de faire le show vous avez vu les faits
parce qu'on a on ne parle que de l'effet
pkp depuis maintenant 9 jours au québec
j'avais vu dans les sondages cette crème
que les gens ont retenu dix ont vu le
bras en l'air en disant je veux un pays
ça a réveillé le débat nationalistes des
bonnes sur la question nationale au
québec
est ce que ça vous regretter un peu
comment ces sorties avec le recul je
pense que l'on doit évidemment vivre
avec les paroles et les gestes que nous
posons en même temps y'a pas que la
souveraineté il ya également à mon
engagement au niveau économique qu'au
niveau des entreprises
est ce que je comprends bien vous dit
même si on peut effrayer sa faim
fédéralisme ou si bien être clair dans
notre proposition politique plaisir on
est souveraine et son époux rené speer
allons-y non pas question de cacher la
vue sur youtube ce débat leur de sa vie
à la campagne électorale parce que
pourquoi la quelle mesure on parle
l'option va vous en avais tes l'image
est forte car karl péladeau qui ont
repris
c'est ce que vous on est clair
ça m'apparaîtrait un curieux que de
penser que lorsque nous nous présentons
pour le parti québécois on se présente
pas pour un parti souverainiste est
selon moi il y en a un parti soirée 10
mai historique et puis jamais caché et
vous avez une orientation politique donc
l'engagement déjà avec le parti
québécois était selon moi un geste de
même nature oui mais vous avez vu
monsieur parizeau réagi en cela andré
victor lévy beaulieu des chroniqueurs
comme foglia j'avais vous êtes un peu le
nouveau lucien bouchard pour ces gens là
qui disent si une chance dit ce qu'elle
a dit ça avec lui nous senti ce poids le
nom oui mais en même temps ce n'était
pas que sur ça c'était souvent donc un
sujet donc je pense que il salue
également la teneur de mon engagement
le soc est indéniable que pour un
dirigeant d'entreprise sans voir un
certain courage
certains diront ou utiliseront dans le
qualificatif
ça vous inquiète pas trop ce que vous
voyez aujourd'hui son âge vous contrôlez
fixe à laquelle le parti québécois de
commandes portant des sandales
non il reste trois semaines de campagne
sur l'économie
quel message ou voulait précisément
envoyé aux jeunes entrepreneurs du
québec la visite je me coupais
l'entrepreneuriat
comment pour ims synthétiser votre
message cette et ise c'est pas
nécessairement facile parce que c'est
une problématique quand même blanche met
donc pas aux défis démographiques que
nous rencontrons comme collectivité
j'avais souvent dit pierre karl péladeau
c'est qu'ils manquent aussi
d'entreprises parce qu' il manque de
richesse au québec pour se payer tout ce
qu'on veut ce pénible au nord le québec
dans le rouge tomate série qui dure
depuis trois ans également de montréal
oui on est très bien mais cette excuse
est difficile ce qu'on veut se payer
puisque en plus pénible
il est là bas j'ai pas si la
problématique de la poule et l'oeuf le 6
mai dans la besoin ou effectivement nous
nous sommes donné un ses programmes
sociaux
encore une fois hérité de notre
situation historique à l'intérieur du
continent nord américain
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que nous devons encore avoir davantage
d'entreprises davantage d'entrepreneurs
davantage d'opportunités à offrir aux
québécois de financer ses programmes
sociaux pour les maintenir les plus
efficaces possibles car perdre ou de
trois questions rapides le facile si
vous êtes élu peu importe partis forment
le gouvernement parce que vous restez
député de saint girons c'est un
engagement à clasher parce que les gens
vont nous poser la question est ce qu'on
peut imaginer pierre karl péladeau dans
l'opposition déjà qu'on n'ose imaginer
qu'au chef est dans l'opposition ça sera
dur
ça j'imagine qu'on est un apprentissage
auquel j'aurais également aussi
énormément plaisir
jimmy a mentionné en cette matière chili
et au fip et puis à l'assemblée
nationale je suis allé en eau n'est
jamais protégé je ne connais pas le
travail parlementaire le chat est là
dans 100 % et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ou si je me présente parce que
votre travail et de représentants du
père donc de parlementaires a effectué
et puis j'ai pas la science infuse moi
l'amitié de temps peur d'aucune façon
délicat et donc je ris à faire mes
classes également sur la question la
propriété il est actionnaire de contrôle
de quebecor beaucoup de gens tous les
mieux qu'on dit c'est que jamais vu qui
venait d'avoir magnat de la presse qui
en mettant une ministre ou député es ce
que vous avez évolué là dessus sous
c'est pour aller plus loin j'avais tout
dit premièrement je pense que c'est
prématuré de répondre à cette question
effectivement vous avez région de l'alt
et aux produits n a qu à cet élu je dois
d'élus d'anciens fleurons ensuite
éventuellement
si le gouvernement québécois est
majoritaire le potentiel donc d'être
dans l'entourage de madame marois puis
en conséquence éventuellement
l'application de la loi telle que celle
qu'elle existe alors j'ai mentionné à
plusieurs reprises que j'avais
l'intention de respecter la loi nous
avons déjà été en communication avec le
comme ça à l'éthique et à la déontologie
mais avant il annonce ce dimanche
dernier en poursuivant des discussions
nous allons échanger sur les tenants et
aboutissants et delon suivre les
recommandations du commissaire à
l'éthique longs moments importants
c'est l'homme qui est à la tête du plus
puissant groupe médiatique au québec on
dit j'ai entendu la semaine dernière
déjà dix attaques et appelle à dos et
s'attaque à l'intégrité des journalistes
moi je crois pas moi je pense que les
journalistes au québec font un travail
rigoureux
un travail qui n'est pas facilitée
emprunt d'embûches mais le problème
c'est ceux qui décident des contenus et
ça on ne peut pas laisser une population
comme celle de saint jérôme un peu à nu
où on va avoir le contrôle de
l'information qui circule alors moi je
dis ça monsieur péladeau de choses vous
voulez faire de la politique choix
merveilleux c'est noble qu'un citoyen
peut s'engager mais qu'il le fasse pour
servir les citoyens non pas pour servir
ses intérêts privés
donc pour vous c'est absolument
exécrable c'est incompatible est par
exemple un super ministre et être en
même temps magnat de la presse mais il
me semble que l'évidence elle est là il
comprenait que des gens disent c'est
difficile son image in mais ce prélat
d'y revenir grands patrons dans l'aide
les avait dit qu'en intervenant pas trop
non plus vous excluez que j'ai jamais
dit que je reviendrai quand prétendre si
vous vendez pas vos actions
est ce que vous savez ce que l'avenir
nous réserve mais non plus alors on
verra au moment important et c'est
pathétique comme question mais chose
certaine c'est une hypothèse sérieuse
dans une société comme le québec on est
dans un trou noir
vous êtes un personnage extrêmement
important dans les médias vous
connaissez donc c'est une question
hypothétique oui tout à fait mes moments
importants alors qu'elle devait
éventuellement se poser
ils auront l'occasion d'y répondre mais
pour l'instant on apparaît prématurée et
beaucoup vont vous dire c'est un peu
david contre goliath dans la région ici
c'est le sentiment c'est l'évocation que
monsieur péladeau comme les journées
pour développer c'est vraiment le
sentiment le commentaire que j'entends
tout genre je parle à des gens ici même
mais avant votre arrivée et puis les
gens nous disaient on regarde on est à
deux doigts est pas question
ce faire l erreur donc nous déjà
premièrement été très bien servi pendant
les 18 mois la coalition était née quand
une la diffusion sa fente si vos pas
l'oublier saint-girons était
sous-financée durant les deux dernières
années et puis et on est rendu compte
évidemment les autorités politiques des
premières les puits avec un gouvernement
majoritaire spécule réjean hébert a déjà
fait une annonce pour le village elle
replace de nous mais c'est clairement je
pense comme j'ai un des lecteurs tout à
l'heure ça va être le tour de ses jets
de pierre karl péladeau alors je vous
souhaite une comme je souhaite à tous
les candidats qu'on rencontre une bonne
campagne c'est tant mieux
merci à brommat aveyron encore davantage
sur la vente comme on dit